hello i'm veteran stuntman stunt
coordinator rick fight today we're going
to break down the action the arts and
science of stunt driving
[Applause]
i've been in the stunt world for about
38 years and when you don't find me on
camera working stunts or choreographing
action you can find me in my karate
school teaching martial arts
today i'll be breaking down the art and
science of stunt driving
the vehicle to demonstrate the making of
a good stunt vehicle i'll be using these
lego technic models just like the real
vehicles they're built tough
all stunt vehicles have reinforced
suspension frames and roofs hand brakes
are added and we have a six point roll
cage and a five point harness before a
big stunt my team will plan it out with
the use of concrete chalk and a
miniature vehicle
a good stunt man always plants his
stunts out on a smaller scale
the classic stunts
maybe we have a scene where our vehicle
has to fly up on two wheels and go down
an alleyway and miss people all right
when we do this we call that high skiing
it's very popular but it's very
difficult to do
one of my favorite stunts is going to be
the reverse j turn it's where we start
our vehicle back it up in reverse
approximately 35 miles an hour whip his
wheel to the left bringing that front
around drop and drive and accelerate
away
ramp jumping we have a stable ramp a
vehicle hits it mark flies in either
pancakes or crashes off that ramp
and now the most popular of all ramps is
the pipe ramp we insert the pipe ramp we
can adjust the height and angle our
vehicle backs up
hits the ramp
launches and twists and turns all the
way over
at the end of the day it all comes down
to safety and preparation
well i really enjoy working with lego
technic
they're as close to the real thing as
possible for us not only are they built
rugged and strong and contain roll cages
that roll
tires of turn
power take off
but they're just fun
well this has been stunt man stunt
coordinator rick fike breaking down the
art and science of stunt driving with
lego technic build for real